Jesse how did you convince your parents
that making a movie was better than
going to college
ah well it took a lot of convincing for
sure
um I think that you know I my whole life
I was just always kind of doing my own
thing making films from an early age and
I it was never one that I really liked
learning in a classroom setting you know
and I kind of knew that
uh
I was probably gonna do it they probably
knew that I was going to do it either
way with or without their help and so
you know they could they could kind of
get behind and try to help me with this
or I would just be going off and doing
it either way and so I think they kind
of knew I was really self-driven and and
had kind of that in me and and that's
just what I thought was best for for me
to learn kind of how to expand my career
but
um you know I had to put together a
budget and proposal and kind of explain
to them how to do this and that I would
hire you know actual you know adult
filmmakers I guess uh and it would be an
actual kind of learning experience it
would basically be my film school just a
totally different version of it you know
and uh yeah it uh
I think once they actually saw it coming
together they realized it really was a
pretty amazing thing to to have pulled
off even to
um and the fact that it ended up getting
a small distributor and and had this
release you know and I think that uh it
was kind of a once in a lifetime kind of
experience just that you know and so
much
came from it both for me personally and
professionally and
it was uh you know I don't necessarily
think that that's what everyone should
do but for me it was the right thing and
and uh really worked out I think were
your parents teachers
no no I mean my dad was like a carpenter
my mom was a small business consultant
so none of them had any sort of you know
connection to film or creativity or or
anything like that but yeah when it was
all said and done how much did it cost
to make that movie
my first feature I think cost about
sixty thousand dollars you know like I
tried to figure out like how could I
make this the smallest amount of money
possible but still make it look and feel
like a real movie
and then how much could I raise you know
I basically how I funded it was I got
friends and family to kind of give money
kind of the Kickstart model Kickstarter
model but like you know this was in 2003
2004 you know even before really that
existed
um but that same idea and and then I
basically went to my parents and said
hey would you consider giving the money
that I would have used you would have
maybe put into helping me with college
to make this movie instead so kind of
putting it all that together plus lots
of other kind of in-kind things uh was
able to make this movie at the age of 17
that you know I mean this was in again
2003 when we shot it I was a senior in
high school or just about to be
um and so you know if you watch it now
it probably wouldn't feel that legit but
but back then it definitely felt and
looked like a real movie and was
definitely uh impressive for us I was so
young to have fold off I guess yeah
how much convincing did that take for
them to put in your quote-unquote
college fund into this film I mean I
think it definitely took a lot of
convincing
um yeah you know at first they didn't
necessarily think that was the best idea
but
I uh they kind of knew I was gonna do it
one way or the other and uh it I just
had always been been like that uh the
film they knew that like you know I
instead of like uh
having other passions or or projects you
know I didn't really do Sports I I
didn't like have a lot of other things
outside of it like this was my passion
you know was making films and
I spent all my time working on it and
writing and creating stuff and so they
just knew that that's what I wanted to
do and that's what I was going to do and
so I think they saw they could they
could actually help me do that and
rather than trying to you know hold me
back or force me to to go down a certain
model you know I could do this and I
would learn something from it either way
you know even if it was a complete
disaster I mean I would learn how to
have made a film and how to almost run a
a business in a sense right because you
have to manage the budget and hire
people and all that sort of stuff and
um my mom was a kind of a business
consultant for helping people start
their own small businesses so she was
she was almost a de facto producer even
though she didn't know anything about it
you know but she was able to kind of
give me all these insight into actually
how to pull that off and everything and
um yeah it was uh definitely an
adventure
so they knew that sort of the Jesse
train was leaving and if they wanted to
get on they could get on but it was
going to happen totally yeah okay yeah
when it was all said and done were they
did they sit you down and say you know
we're glad we did this and this is
pretty cool definitely no I think the
first time I put together like a little
trailer while we were editing the movie
and they saw it and I think they were
kind of blown away because they hadn't
really seen much while I was filming and
making the movie
you know they were supporting by like
you know helping do some craft service
and stuff but they barely even came to
the set like they kind of let me do my
own thing and so when they saw it yeah I
think they were kind of completely blown
away because it was such a different
elevation beyond what I had done before
you know which was much more of a home
movie style kind of thing you know and
so uh yeah I know they were really
impressed and I think realized it was uh
no matter what would happen with it it
was it would have been worth it for kind
of the experience I'd learned all the
different aspects of kind of pulling
this together what I had learned and and
the experience I'd gotten from it so you
still had to go back to morning classes
or whatever even after you shot it and
you're still in high school as a senior
yeah totally so I shot it between the
summer of my Junior and Senior year and
so then I basically was editing it after
school during my senior year
um again I hired like a real editor
let's say like not just my friend like
someone who was
um a grown-up I guess you know because I
was like 17 18 years old
um who had done a couple films and so he
would basically edit it during the day
and I would go to his house after I left
school in the afternoon and uh we would
work out a seed and then I'd do that the
next day and
um yeah so while my friends were going
to like I don't know what after school
you know they would always ask me to
hang out and be like sorry I can't I
gotta go into my movie you know and they
didn't really realize you know what I
was actually working on and what I was
doing but uh uh yeah it was definitely a
a different kind of senior year but
um it was awesome and this was all
before dslrs too correct so yeah we Shot
the movie on it was called like DVC Pro
50 you know so this was almost like
before HD was even like HD cam was just
starting to come out this was like
you know this was this weird time period
in the early 2000s where
you know cameras were still kind of
figuring themselves out yeah this was
before DSLR this was like a kind of
you know a very weird time of of
transition I guess you know
um
you know for me personally like I
started editing on like taped tape with
like VHS you know tapes that was kind of
my generation LH and then uh By the time
by the time we started making the
feature where I was editing on you know
uh with Final Cut I guess at the time
and uh but yeah it was uh it was it was
the area where you still had to like you
know make a DVD to be able to like watch
it at your house or whatever you know
so yeah
the movie was living life correct yeah a
movie was called living life it was
uh it was about a teenage boy who gets
cancer and kind of what he does with his
life after that kind of a coming-of-age
movie it would feel like a Hallmark or
kind of like Lifetime movie now it's not
I I don't really know why I made this
movie it hasn't it had no personal
connection at the time to it I think I'd
become really interested in just the
fact that films could make you feel
something and I was trying to kind of
tap into some sort of emotion and
I think at the time too there was there
were so many films that were kind of
dealing with that subject of like loss
or dying and I think that was my kind of
how a lot of filmmakers copy something
when they're starting out you know
rather than copying the exact story I
was kind of copying this mood that I
wanted to create and the mood was was I
guess to make people sad or make people
feel something and so that's kind of
where that idea came from it's not the
film I would have I would make now and
it's not the film I think I should have
made
um but I was able to kind of weave in
elements for my life and kind of this
kind of teenage angst kind of vibe I
guess of figuring that self out but uh
because the main character was my same
age but the other more serious parts of
this the film didn't have any I didn't
have something I could relate to in that
sense so I think that part is probably
the weaker part of the film because it's
not it's not the authentic part you know
and that's
um but I think that was one of the great
learning experiences of making it was
just kind of realizing
you know whatever you write it really
has to come from some part it has to
come from you and and you got to find
that kind of personal connection to
really make it feel authentic and real
you know and
um so
I think uh I think that's really what I
what I took away from making it is just
kind of whatever I was going to write
next or the story I was going to make
next had to have something that was even
stronger of a kind of personal
connection even if it's the characters
themselves you know writing more of
myself into them or something like that
and I think that first film because I
was so young I wrote it probably started
writing when I was 15 or 16 years old
just didn't have that because I didn't
understand at the time you know that's
really what you had to do you know
what were some of the mistakes that you
made on the film looking back
I think the main mistakes would be one
is just the script not being strong
enough and not having the the real
personal
connection that I could authentically
kind of tell that story in the best way
possible
and then I think the other aspect was
just under
utilizing kind of the actors and
realizing because up until this point
I'd use my friends and friends of
friends you know my parents friends to
be my actors right and this was my first
time working with professional actors
and so that was really overwhelming and
and didn't really know how to kind of
fully get everything out of them I think
you know and
so
I think if I had done it again I would
have made another short or something
first maybe with with professional
actors or kind of I don't know it's it's
hard to say because it's I when I went
to go make this movie I never thought
okay this is going to be some huge
success I never thought it would even
get distributed it was really supposed
to be kind of my way of going to film
school and learning and that's what it
was it's just if I'm thinking of it as
like the critical side of like how could
it have been the best movie that's
probably what I should have done but uh
in a sense it was It was kind of this
like film school learning experience all
wrapped into into making a movie I guess
um
it would probably be the best way you
could actually become a filmmaker it
just would be probably the most
expensive and wasteful way if you if you
didn't you know have it all figured out
I guess too but
um yeah
you tell a similar story to other
filmmakers who have let's say student
loans from Film School do they comment
do they say anything I mean so yeah I
mean I've met a lot of young filmmakers
in my day
um uh both as a filmmaker and then I ran
this film festival for young directors
for many years and so I've met every
kind of filmmaker for once they went to
really expensive fancy film schools to
didn't go to any film school and I think
the the thing is that there's no perfect
or right way for everyone you know it's
like everyone learns differently you
know for me I just never in general with
school I didn't like being in a
classroom and having to kind of sit and
learn I want to just get in there and
grab the camera and do it you know
because that's how I learned it from the
very beginning as a little kid and so
I think for me I realized just film
school it's not I mean I looked at some
film scores I thought about it it's not
like I was like anti-film school it just
I also really wanted to just make a
movie and start doing it and so I kind
of realized you know I maybe couldn't do
both you know I couldn't do one or the
other and so if I had the opportunity to
make a feature I should go do that but
that being said um I think there's a
huge amount of advantages to film School
number one probably the people you meet
at it and the relationships you can
build that you can kind of carry on for
the rest of your career and and just
even in your social life
um and uh of course uh you can always
learning more about filmmaking is never
going to hurt you right so even if uh
you don't think you need or don't want
it it can all it's always going to open
up something else and and then probably
inspire you in some other way so
um definitely not anti-film school but I
think that if uh you really want to be a
director I wouldn't necessarily go to
the most expensive Film School put all
your money into that you know there are
other ways to learn and maybe save some
of that money to go make it a short or
something at least afterwards
so you're I hate to use this term a
self-starter it sounds like a something
on your resume but I mean it sounds like
you like to just be in the action you
like to do things yourself 100 yeah I
mean I
ever since a young age I was always very
like entrepreneurial I guess
um because even when I before I was
making movies I was like
as a kid I had like a newspaper and then
you know I was I was actually a magician
for a while as a kid like like a legit
one that would do parties and stuff like
that cool
I did I did some acting but more like I
put on the plays in a lot of ways so I
was always just kind of trying to
entertain people
um and kind of uh put together
experiences I guess
um I was also a very shy kid and so I
wasn't it was kind of this opposite side
of my personality where I would be very
shy but then when I could actually put
together some sort of like experience I
would kind of turn on or whatever but
yeah I always I always just liked
creating things and making people feel
something you know whether that was from
putting on a play or making a little
short film or whatever and I think I
just realized
you know because unless I just figured
out how to do it myself no one was going
to show me
um because especially back then it's
like you know you I didn't even own a
camera myself when I was a kid I mean we
I borrowed my neighbor's old VHS camera
like that's how I made my first little
movies you know and so it's just so
different back then where you couldn't
just pick up an iPhone and start making
it you know you had to uh you just had
to kind of figure it out so I think
that's where a lot of that came from was
just kind of like having a force having
to figure out how to make this and and
pull it off and
and I think too just for my
personalities when I decide I'm gonna do
something I just go all in and so
whether it's the film or whatever I'm
going to do it's like if I decide I'm
going to do that then yeah I'm gonna
have to dive in and figure it out and
take on every aspect of it to kind of
piece it together
and I bet there's so many elements that
cross over between being a magician and
film
because your sleight of hand of so many
things for sure and that was actually
one aspect I worked into that first
feature there was this little Side Story
with uh him learning magic from his
grandfather that had been kind of
separated from the family and teaching
and doing magic at the hospital where he
was being treated you know
um which sounds like kind of a sappy
store but actually I was doing that at
that same time I was a magician I would
go to these hospitals sometimes and do
magic and so I was able to kind of take
that kind of story from my own life and
yeah you know I think I I think magic
and film is very similar because it's
it's both kind of creating this illusion
or whatever
um and I just love nothing more than
being able to whether it was doing a
magic trick back then which I don't do
anymore or uh film magic trick or
whatever but making somebody feel
something that that's really where I I
guess I can get off or whatever you want
to call it like basically uh you know
witnessing someone
uh have a reaction to something you've
you've created I just think is so
amazing and so if you can do that
um in whatever form uh it's just it's so
so exciting to me so yeah